what really started i got arrested like
probably five five four years ago or
whatever the cop pulled me out the car
and he said hey that's an awful lot of
cough syrup because he found all the
pints in the back seat of the car you
know what i mean and then from then on
it's just like it's just always been
like this viral clip and then i always
made clothes so one day i'm just like
you know i'm steadily like
bleaching and tie-dying other people's
clothes and trying to like do stuff to
other people stuff but i never had
nothing that was mine and then i
literally was just there one day like
bro why don't i just put this on a shirt
like just that's an awful lot of coffee
and then ever since then it's just i put
it on a shirt started with one t-shirt
i used to catch the bus to the slots and
swap meet you know i'll get them heat
pressed on like 12 shirts give away 10
sell two the two i made i'll use two two
i sold i'll use that money to make some
more
damn and it's crazy too because like
during that
era like
that was really like
that was when like lean was really
booming the drug use in hip-hop i mean
it still is right but i mean like
it was like yeah it was like really
booming but it's crazy that that all
kind of
started from an actual interaction you
had from getting arrested [ __ ] turned
the negative to the positive people